trump brings hunter biden's former
business partner to the final debate as
the media studiously avoid the story
good trump shows up for the debate
mostly and joe biden pledges to end
the oil industry i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind signed up now
at expressvpn.com well we'll get to
more of the news in just one second
we'll get to all of the news in fact
because there is plenty of it but first
we need to talk about your safety and
security
online now here's the reality those
social media companies that you don't
trust because they are suppressing your
ability to actually see information
they're actually using your data to
monetize all that nonsense they're using
your data and they're selling it to
advertisers and there's no reason they
should be allowed to do that also
hackers are looking for your data so
they can make money off of you why would
you allow them to do that either instead
use expressvpn if you've ever wondered
how free to access sites make their
money it's by tracking your searches
video history everything you click on
and then selling
your valuable data well when you use
expressvpn you anonymize much of your
online presence by hiding that ip
address
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers
expressvpn
really really easy to set up you tap one
button on your phone or computer you are
now protected voila
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
data to protect you
from hackers and internet bad guys it's
finally time to say no to censorship
take back your online privacy at
expressvpn.com by visiting my special
link
you get an extra three months of
expressvpn service for free again that
is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
expressivevpn.com to protect your data
today okay so last night represented the
final presidential debate we are
reaching the end of the road here
we are less than a week and a half out
from the presidential election of 2020
and so the pressure was on for president
trump
and he showed up he showed up and he
performed to understand exactly how this
debate went however we have to backtrack
a little bit we have to do the run-up to
the debate so
late yesterday afternoon just before the
debate there was a press conference
called by the trump campaign this press
conference
was very much reminiscent of the press
conference that president trump held
with
accusers against bill clinton back in
2016 he brought a bunch of women who had
accusations against bill clinton and
suggested that hillary clinton
had covered all of that up and and all
that sort of thing
this was very reminiscent of that he
brought forth a guy named tony
bobolinski bob linski was a former
would-be business partner
of hunter biden and he alleges that it
wasn't just that hunter biden was going
around the globe picking up bags of cash
he alleges that he was doing so on
behalf of the biden family he says he
has the receipts to prove it that joe
biden actually knew what was going on
that joe biden
was involved now as we will see it is
not clear
at all from the documentary evidence
that has been thus far
presented that joe biden was deeply
involved in his son hunter's business
however there are certainly implications
in the hunter biden emails that suggest
it as far as money actually changing
hands again there's
no actual documentary implication that
money has actually changed hands and has
been funneled directly to
joe biden we'll get to that in a second
right because the media are studiously
avoiding the story except for maybe the
wall street journal which is now
reporting on it
but tony bobolinsky did this press
conference and again this was right
before
the debate and suddenly made this story
a lot more serious because
before it had just been all of these
emails that had sort of been dripped out
via the new york post they'd been put
out a little bit via fox news
well now you actually had a face of a
person who worked with hunter biden
saying that joe was intimately involved
with the business so bob linski gets up
in basically a spare room
in nashville tennessee and he says i was
told earlier this week that if i reveal
what i know it's going to bury all of us
meaning the biden family as well
i was told this past sunday by somebody
who was also involved in this matter
that if i went public this information
it'd be it would bury all of us
man the biden's included
i have no wish to bury anyone i've never
been political
the few contributions i've made have
been the democrats
but what i am is a patriot and a veteran
okay bob linsky also suggested that he
had
privy inside knowledge to everything
that was going on in hunter biden's
business
he spoke deliberately of a may 13 2017
email
in which it was discussed how much of an
interest in a chinese company would be
held
by h h meaning hunter biden apparently
was twenty percent
and some ten percent going to the big
guy so bob linski said the big guy here
was
joe biden which of course would take
this from the realm of joe kind of knew
and patted his son on the head as his
son went around picking up bags of cash
which is
extremely plausible and in fact probable
there's a line between that and joe
biden actually received money
from these sort of corrupt goings on
again if biden did this
after he was vice president it is not a
violation of the law he's allowed to do
it after he is vice president
it does certainly look like influence
peddling however and
joe biden apparently was in contact with
hunter about this stuff
according to bobolinsky as early as 2015
2016 when he actually was vice president
in any case
here was bob linski saying that the h in
that email said for hunter
and biden was the big guy on may 13
2017 i received an email concerning
allocation of equity
which says 10 percent held by h for the
big guy
in that email there's no question that h
stands for hunter
big guy for his father joe biden
and jim for jim biden in fact hunter
often
referred to his father as the big guy or
my chairman
yeah he says he came forward bobolinsky
did because he was tired of hearing
joe biden suggest that he had never
discussed business with hunter when
babalinski says i know firsthand that
that is false i've been at dinners where
they've discussed business
i've heard joe biden say that he's never
discussed business with hunter
that is false i have firsthand knowledge
about this because i directly dealt with
the biden family including joe biden
i was introduced to joe biden by jim
biden and hunter biden
at approx and at my approximately
hour-long meeting with joe
that night we discussed the biden's
history
the biden's family business plans with
the chinese with which he was plainly
familiar
at least at a high level okay and then
bob linski
held up some cell phones and he said all
the evidence of what i'm saying is on
these phones i've turned these over
to the proper authorities who was bob
linsky yesterday
tomorrow i will be meeting with the
senate committee members concerning this
matter
and i will be providing to the fbi the
devices which contain
the evidence corroborating what i have
said the evidence sits on these three
phones i don't want to go into anything
any further uh this will all be
discussed with uh
senator johnson and his committee and
the american people can decide what's
fact
okay so that is where things stood until
just before the debate finally the biden
campaign
put out what seems to be a pretty
comprehensive statement denying the
story
according to the biden campaign quote as
chris wallace said on air about this
very smear vice president biden has
actually released his tax returns unlike
president trump
and there is no indication he ever got
any money from anybody in these business
deals
joe biden has never even considered
being involved in business with his
family
nor in any overseas business whatsoever
he has never held stock in any such
business arrangements nor has any family
member or any other person
ever held stock for him what is true is
that tony babalinsky admitted on the
record to breitbart that he is angry he
was not able to go into business with
hunter and james biden what is also true
is that in contrast to vice president
biden donald trump has a secret chinese
bank account and pays more in taxes in
china than he pays in federal income tax
in the united states
and this is a desperate pathetic farce
executed by a flailing campaign with no
rationale for putting our country
through another
four years of hell okay so that is a
pretty comprehensive denial
by the biden campaign their ways to spin
it where it looks as though maybe
there's some hair splitting
so for example you could say well maybe
the stock is in stock maybe it's
some other form of asset right not all
ownership in a company comes in the form
of actual stock i could say that maybe
you could say that
joe biden didn't have to be involved
with the overseas business
he could have just been sort of a
passive partner in the overseas business
there are ways to parse this
in which theoretically biden couldn't be
denying the story but it looks mostly
overall like biden is denying the story
and the denial is blanket enough that if
any of that ended up being true
biden would get excoriated for it so the
wall street journal has a couple of
pieces
further explicating the story itself
we'll get to those in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
it's been a pretty dark year i mean
really kind of a
terrifying year in a lot of ways between
covet and wildfires and
earthquakes and hurricanes and
everything else you might be thinking
about life insurance like what do i do
to protect my family in case god forbid
something should happen
to me well shopping for life insurance
can seem daunting policy genius makes it
easy they combine a cutting-edge
insurance marketplace with help from
licensed experts to save you
time and money right now you could say
50 or more by using policy genius to
compare life
insurance when you're shopping for a
policy that could last for more than a
decade the savings really do start to
add up here's how it works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price policy
genius will compare policies starting
at as little as one dollar a day you
might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape
the best part they work for you not the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything soup to
nuts so if you need life insurance head
on over to policygenius.com right now to
get started you could save 50
or more by comparing quotes today policy
genius when it comes to
insurance it is nice and extremely
extremely important to
get it right okay so the wall street
journal has a couple of reports
detailing the rest of the sort of
bobolinsky story one
the headline says hunter biden's ex
business partner alleged father knew
about venture however
corporate records reviewed by the wall
street journal show no record for joe
biden according to the wall street
journal
the biden campaign denied that joe had
any involvement in this chinese venture
with his
oil company or stood to gain by it
babalinski said he was ranked by joe
biden's public statements he never
discussed the international business
activities of hunter and other family
members he also cited nearly five
million dollars in payments a senate
republican report last month
said that cefc made 200 biden's law firm
as another reason
to come forward babalinski said he took
part in a meeting with hunter joe biden
and joe biden's brother james biden in
la in 2017
when they discussed the biden family
business plans with the chinese of which
joe biden was plainly familiar
at least at a high level a biden
campaign spokesman didn't immediately
respond to a question about the alleged
meeting with babalinski james biden and
an attorney for hunter biden didn't
respond to requests for comment and then
they of course
issued from the campaign this blanket
denial
text messages and emails related to the
venture that were provided to the
journal by bob linski mainly from the
spring and summer of 2017
don't show either hunter biden or james
biden discussing a role for joe in the
venture
mr gilliard who is one of the partners
told the journal i would like to clear
up any speculation that former vp biden
was involved with the 2017 discussions
about our potential business structure
i'm unaware of any involvement at any
time of the former vp the activity in
question
never delivered any project revenue and
which sounds like
maybe just maybe the project was on the
road and then it sort of fell apart
kimberly strassel has a report over at
the wall street journal on this
she says that bobolinsky's text messages
show he was recruited for the project by
that james gillier character a hunter
associate
gilliard explains in a december 2015
text there will be a deal between the
chinese and quote one of the most
prominent families from the united
states
a month later he introduces rob walker
also a partner of biden in march 2016
gilliard told the babalinski the chinese
entity was cefc
which was shaping up to be the goldmans
of china meaning goldman sachs
he later promised that same month to
develop the terms of a deal with hunter
at this point joe biden of course was
still vice president as the deal began
to take shape in 2017 bobolinsky began
to question
what hunter would contribute besides his
name and worried he was quote kicked out
of the u.s navy for cocaine use hillary
acknowledged skill sets missing and
observed that hunter has a few demons
he explained that in brand hunter is
imperative but right now he's not
essential
for adding input hunter was hardly
visible through most of the work until
final negotiations ramped up in mid-may
he brought in his uncle jim biden
for a stake hunter and texan emails
wanted offices in three u.s cities
significant travel budgets a stipend for
jim a job for an assistant
and more frequent distributions of any
gains and of course he explained that he
wanted a hell of a lot more than 850 000
per year because his ex-wife would
nearly take all of it
hunter repeatedly made clear that his
contribution was his name
he railed at babalinski that the cefc
heads are coming to be my partner
to be partners with the bidens he then
reminds him that in this instance only
one player holds the trump card and
that's me
may not be fair but it's the reality
because i'm the only one putting on and
putting an entire family legacy
on the line joe biden claims he had
never discussed his son's business but
of course there was that may 2017
expectations letter
including that 10 4 quote unquote the
big guy in one text
hunter said quote my chairman give an
emphatic no to a version of the deal
bobolinsky suggested that the chairman
referred to joe biden
the deal fell through on the chinese end
in the summer of 2017. so
is it possible that hunter was
freelancing that he was going around
that joe had spent years basically
patting him on the head telling him to
go pick up bags of cash if he could help
him and that now
joe was out of office and hunter wanted
to help him out so he was freelancing
and every so often he would run
something by joke certainly possible
certainly plausible
is it true that joe biden while he was
vp probably knew what hunter was up to
yeah that is that is probably true
okay so here is the problem nobody in
the media wants to talk about this story
at all they don't find it
interesting or fascinating at all that
joe biden has
throughout his career engaged in sort of
the low-level corruption that many
public officials do right getting
sweetheart mortgages and that sort of
thing
well or at least a sweetheart land deal
from from people who are interested in
some of the legislation on the table
when he was in the senate
and npr put out an actual statement
before the denial before the denial from
the biden campaign
here's what npr's public editor said
quote we don't want to waste our time on
stories that are not really stories and
we don't want to waste listeners in
reader's time on stories that are just
pure distraction
that is unbelievable that is a
taxpayer-funded
journalistic institution openly
declaring that they simply will not
engage
that they are not interested whatsoever
in the story
preemptively so the media i mean so all
this is the lead up to the debate right
the media
are obviously and clearly on the side of
joe biden which means
that the debate the stakes are really
high because now this is basically the
last chance
for trump to set the table for trump to
change the topic and for trump to shift
the course
of the race now members of the media
again it wasn't just npr
many members of the media were over and
over declaring
that the hunter biden story was not in
fact a story they kept declaring without
any evidence whatsoever that it was
russian disinformation
so nbc's hallie jackson she actually
just continued to say that this is
russian descent from there's no
information this is russian
disinformation at this point
the dni john ratcliffe has openly denied
that the hunter biden emails are russian
disinformation by the way
no one has yet suggested that the hunter
biden emails and texts are fake
because they are not as it turns out it
doesn't matter the the great journalists
over at nbc are declaring this stuff
russian's disinformation
you also have the president focusing uh
it seems on hunter biden joe biden's son
and his dealings overseas these
unverified emails
many intelligence experts have said
those emails carry all the
hallmarks rather of a disinformation
foreign disinformation campaign
essentially
uh that is absolutely wrong and again it
is not just the media with regard to the
hunter biden story
it's with regard to everything right
leslie stahl did the 60 minutes episode
with trump
and it sounds like she was pretty
adversarial toward trump like
over and over and over trump said to
stahl you won't ask biden tough
questions that of course is exactly true
the interview went so poorly that trump
decided to basically
throw out the entire interview into the
public view he he took his own tape
by the way it's not a bad idea he took
his own public tape and then he just
threw it out there
here was trump saying to stall you're
not going to ask biden any tough
questions
your first statement to me this is going
to be tough questions
well i don't mind that but when you set
up the interview you didn't say that
you said oh let's have a lovely
interview and and here's what i do say
you don't ask joe biden i saw your
interview with joe
the interviewer i never did a joke it
was a joke
the interview 60 minutes i see joe biden
giving softball after softball i've seen
all of his interviews
he's never been asked a question that's
hard okay and then leslie stall went out
of her way to defend
hunter biden and suggest there was
nothing to any of the allegations like
in the middle of the interview with
trump which is you know heavy journalism
here
i think it's one of the biggest scandals
i've ever seen and you don't cover it
you want to talk about well because it
can't be verified we want to talk about
insignificant things i'm telling you of
course it can be verified
excuse me they found the laptop leslie
marathon
what can't be verified the laptop why do
you say that
even the family hasn't uh trump is
exactly right here of course okay so
this is the burden for trump going into
the debate
is that he has to fight not just joe
biden who really has been able to hide
out in his basement the entire campaign
he has to fight a media that overtly
wishes to see him lose they're very
obvious that they don't wish to cover
anything that has to do with joe biden
so that was the setup now kristen welker
who is the moderator last night
from nbc uh she was widely expected by
people on the right not to be very good
it turns out that she actually did a
fairly good job last night
yes her questions were biased from the
left but overall she did a pretty fair
job as trump himself
acknowledged which was good it gave
trump an opportunity to actually ask
some tough questions
and trump did show up to play it was a
very different trump who showed up to
the debate
last night than the first debate in the
first debate he wanted to be aggressive
but because i i think as i mentioned in
the past
week and a half ever since the
commission on presidential debate
announced they were gonna mute the mics
i thought that was actually very good
for trump because it essentially
cudgeled him
into doing what he should have been
doing anyway which is let joe biden talk
and then pick him apart
after joe biden talks and that happened
repeatedly last night this is a much
better debate for president trump i
thought the first debate was basically a
disaster area for him i thought it
underscored all the worst things about
him
the debate last night allowed him to
highlight aspects of his record that
were good
it allowed him to really badger joe
biden when he needed to badger joe biden
about the fact that joe biden is a
career politician
who happens to be low-level corrupt and
has been for a very very long time
until it allowed him to point out that
joe biden has been useless for five
decades in the senate and then as
vice president it was a good showing for
trump
now it would have been better if the
moderator had actually allowed there to
be talk of foreign policy because
foreign policy has actually been trump's
strong suit
there are a few aspects of foreign
policy that got touched on but overall
a much much better showing for trump
every memorable moment of the debate
last night was a trump moment
every single one in the last one that
was true too but that's just because he
was talking over biden the whole time
and the most memorable moment of that
debate was probably biden telling him to
shut up
in this debate the memorable moments all
came from trump and they all left
biden wrong footed and on the defense so
the first question to be asked about the
debate is number one whether it could
possibly make a difference
the the polls after the debate for what
they are worth showed not a lot of
movement that's not a great shock but
i don't think that the debate for trump
was really so much about
getting independents to vote for him
rather than to biden i think what it was
about
was making republicans more comfortable
voting for him
so i put out this video a week ago now
talking about why i was gonna vote for
trump and i laid for three reasons why i
was gonna vote for trump
the first reason was because trump has
governed much more conservative than i
thought he was
the second reason which is the one under
dispute is i said that most of the
damage or
all of the damage that i think trump has
done to the public discourse
and to the social fabric through his
personality the damage is already done
and it can't be undone so there's no
point in not voting for him it's not
gonna worsen trump is the same every day
and then there's point number three
which is the democrats have gone damned
crazy they've lost their mind
well i think that last night all three
of those points were proved
trump was very conservative last night
he said a lot of very good conservative
things
second trump contained himself right and
this was the big one
trump contained himself because as guy
benson my friend guy benson
over at townhall.com and fox news has
said my second point was the one that
people
some people on the right quibble with
right some of the people who have not
yet quote unquote come home for trump
they'll say well yeah but i'm still too
uncomfortable with trump to vote for him
yeah i know that you're right he's more
conservative and that biden and the
democrats have gone wild left
but i'm still really uncomfortable trump
made people feel more comfortable on the
right last night
independents are still going to feel
uncomfortable with him but overall
trump's personality
last night his willingness to discuss
his own record
last night it was so much better and it
made people i think
who were hesitant to vote for trump but
were going to vote for trump if forced
to the choice they'd vote for trump over
biden but they were hesitant to actually
go out to the polls i think now they
will be more enthusiastic about going
out to the polls and that may make a
huge difference
in a lot of these very very tight swing
states again the swing states right now
are still
extremely tight the national race seems
like it is a quote-unquote runaway
although it looks like the numbers are
starting to drop a little bit for joe
biden the real clear politics national
average
has now dropped below eight percent for
the first time in several weeks and
there are
several polls showing this thing very
close there's an ibd tipp
poll that came out yesterday showing
biden up only four
there is a rasmussen report poll that
came out the day before showing biden up
only three
there are other reports from economist
and reuters that still have biden up
nine or ten but you're starting to see
more of these sort of outlying polls
there's a hill harris poll that showed
biden up only four
right there there are a few outlying
polls that are starting to show just
glimmers just glimmers that perhaps
trump isn't down all that far nationally
and in the states he is not down all
that far
right if you look at north carolina it's
basically within margin of error ohio is
within margin of error
florida is within margin of error
if you look at arizona arizona there's a
poll yesterday that showed that that
essentially it was
a one-point race in arizona meaning
within margin of error instead even in
arizona
i had on chris polster kristen sultan
sanderson on the radio show yesterday
and
she sort of laid forth the various
scenarios by which trump could win she
said there's basically two sets of
states to watch
there's the sun belt and then there's
the rust belt states i'll explain what
to watch
in just one second first let's talk for
a second about
it's pretty obvious when you don't get a
good night's rest so last night i did
not get a good night's rest i was up
until very very late covering the debate
then i was up very very early this
morning that means on the moments in
between when my
young daughter was not waking me up to
have yet another bottle because she is a
growing and babbling baby
when she was not doing that i needed to
sleep and that is why i'm so grateful
that i have a helix sleep mattress he
looks asleep they've got a quiz it takes
just two minutes for you to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plusher from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine cnn
called the most comfortable mattress
they've ever slept on just head on over
to
ben take their two minutes sleep because
they will match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life they've got a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners right
now get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.com
that is helixsleep.com ben
okay so in those state polls again
you've got the sunbelt states and you've
got the rust belt states the sun belt
states
are arizona florida north carolina trump
needs to win all three he won all three
last time then you have the rust belt
states those are wisconsin michigan
pennsylvania
if trump wins the sun belt states he
needs to win at least one of the rust
belt states
and right now michigan looks like he's
getting away from him the polls in
michigan
look pretty broad at this point if you
look at wisconsin wisconsin is about a
five-point biden lead
so it's within kind of vision uh and
pennsylvania is also within about five
so both of those are maybes for trump
if you really stretch right if things
really change just
three points maybe then you could see
trump picking that up and then you can
see polar
playing with the rest so trump needs to
make a move in wisconsin and
pennsylvania
in arizona as i've said he's running
very close in florida very close in
north carolina
very close okay so that marginal change
could make a huge difference for trump
this is why that debate mattered now
people are going to point out that not a
lot of people change their mind again
not about people changing their mind
it's about the level of enthusiasm for
trump and i'm not talking about like the
hardcore trump base i'm talking about
people
who look at trump cringe a little and
think do i really need to vote for that
guy
well last night he made them a little
more comfortable voting for him as i've
always said
the art of politics is making it very
difficult to vote for your opponent and
very easy to vote for you
trump has generally been pretty good at
the former and very bad at the latter
last night he was much better
at the latter and that was a big big
thing okay so now finally
we reached the debate the stakes were
quite high
the debate opened with talk about covid
so
this is always a topic that is going to
be a problem for trump
simply because no matter who's president
of the united states if a bunch of
people die while you're presidents of
the united states people tend to blame
you
we have this very paganistic view in the
united states what the president can do
if the economy is bad
it's the president's fault if the
economy is good it's the president's
credit if people die it's the
president's fault if people don't die
it's to the president's credit
it's this bizarre sort of weird
fixation on who is the president of the
united states though the president has a
magic wand and can just make everything
better
at a moment's notice so if there's a
pandemic and it kills 200 000 people
obviously that's not going to redound to
the benefit of the president and this is
where biden really looked to make
hay early on in the debate so the truth
is that trump's first answer on covet
was pretty good right he could have
expressed it
more smoothly but his general take was
listen
this has been bad it's also a global
pandemic and pretending that we did
anything that is sort of an outlying
policy or that we blew it in some
serious way
i'm going to need to see some evidence
of that here was trump yesterday 2.2
million
people modeled out were expected to die
it's a worldwide pandemic it's all over
the world you see the spikes in europe
and many other places right now
i can tell you from personal experience
that
i was in the hospital i had it and i got
better and i will tell you that
i had something that they gave me a
therapeutic i guess they would call it
some people could say it was a cure
but uh i was in for a short period of
time and i got better very fast or i
wouldn't be here tonight
it will go away and as i say we're
rounding the turn we're rounding the
corner it's going away
okay so that sort of language is what
joe biden has historically pounced on so
joe biden has been telling one lie
on covet it's a lie the media wish to
reflect and that is that if
donald trump had handled this wildly
differently then
hundreds of thousands of people will be
alive today hundreds of thousands of
people if you've got an empty chair at
your table that is donald
trump's fault if jason from the
halloween thrillers is in the closet
that is donald trump's fault if the dog
crap the carpet that's donald trump's
fault
right kovid which again has killed
literally
hundreds of thousands of people all
across the world if donald trump had not
been president everything would have
been hunky-dory here in the united
states
which is weird because it turns out that
a lot of places where democrats are in
charge
lots and lots of people died in fact on
a death-per-million basis
virtually all of the worst states in
terms of who is hardest hit
were democratic states okay but joe
biden has this narrative he's going to
run with it and the narrative is it's
all
doom and gloom of course the moment that
biden is elected it won't be doom and
gloom anymore is the idea but here was
joe biden
overtly suggesting that donald trump is
responsible for every american who died
of cove which is just crazy i mean i'm
sorry it's a crazy
immoral statement it is immoral to
suggest this it's absolutely immoral
it's it's i i can't express how immoral
i think it is to suggest that the
president of the united states is
responsible for every single person who
dies
while they are president of the united
states from a global pandemic that has
taken hundreds of thousands of lives
all across the world but here is joe
biden making that suggestion anyway
220 000 americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
if we just wore these masks the
president's own advisors have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
this is the same fellow told you this is
going to end by easter last time this is
the same fellow who told you that
don't worry we're going to end this by
the summer we're about to go into a dark
winter
a dark winter and he has no clear plan
and there's no prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year okay so if if trump ends up
winning the election in a week and a
half
one big reason is going to be because
people don't want the doom and gloom
they don't want to hear the doom and
gloom that is doom and gloom stuff there
from joe biden
there's not going to be a vaccine until
the middle of next year
he's lying about the vaccine if
everybody just wore the mask you would
have saved a hundred thousand lives
which again i have serious doubts as to
whether that is in fact the case
considering that if you look at the
actual data what you see is that when
there are spikes people put on the masks
virtually everywhere in the united
states red states blue states as soon as
there are spikes people put on the masks
and by the way
in italy the masking is really heavy and
they're seeing a second surge in cases
anyway
and so so joe biden is preaching doom
and gloom
right trump is not preaching doom and
gloom and so this is where i think trump
started to make hey he started to turn
the tide i thought about 15 minutes into
this discussion when he started talking
about lockdown policy and
biden didn't want to hear anything about
it right biden doesn't want to hear that
we're going to reopen biden doesn't want
to hear any of that he wants to keep
talking us back into the basement
he wants to keep talking us back into
cover depression he believes that if
we're depressed about covered we vote
for him
so believe it or not trump is the
candidate of optimism on kovid
it is biden who is the candidate of
pessimism doom and gloom eternal nuclear
winter
here was trump versus biden on this
issue we're learning to live with it we
have no choice we can't lock ourselves
up in a basement like
joe does he has the he has the ability
to lock himself up i don't know he's
obviously made a lot of money someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement or in a beautiful room in the
white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that i
caught it i learned a lot i learned a
lot
great doctors great hospitals and now i
recovered
99 99.9 of young people recover
99 of people recover we have to recover
we can't close up our nation we have to
open our school
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have a nation
and of course the cdc has said young
people can get sick with covet 19 and
can pass it
people are learning to die with it you
folks home will have an empty chair at
the kitchen table this morning
that man or wife going to bed tonight
and reaching over to try to touch their
out of habit where their wife or husband
was
is gone learning to live with it come on
we're dying with it because he has never
said he said it's dangerous
when's the last time is it really
dangerous still are we dangerous you
tell the people it's dangerous now
what should they do about the danger and
you say i take no responsibility
okay i don't know what the hell biden is
talking about at the end there but that
is the contrast in vision
right trump saying correctly we have to
learn to live with it which by the way
is the exact same thing european leaders
are saying emmanuel macron has said this
boris johnson has said this everyone in
europe is saying
the exact same thing joe biden is saying
we can't learn to live with it we have
to
we're learning to die with it right it's
all like apocalyptic doom saying
from joe biden over and over and over
and then he went on to say we're going
to lose another 200 000 people
by the end of the winter right okay
that's
i mean if you're trying to scare the
living crap out of people so they'll
vote for you good luck
i mean if i think there may be a secret
backlash to this right if the polls are
wrong and i'm not saying the polls are
wrong because
i tend to be much more of a pole
believer than most other people but
if the polls are wrong it's because
they're underestimating the amount that
americans are
sick and tired of hearing from democrats
how many americans are going to die at
trump's hands and that we can never go
back to regular life and that we will be
wearing masks for the rest of eternity
and that our businesses will be locked
down
if there is a brewing sort of under uh
brewing underground against lockdown
culture it's going to manifest in
in the election so we'll see whether
that whether that happens
joe biden for his part he denied he was
going to shut down the country
but then he suggested he's going to shut
down the virus not the country so i'm
going to shut down the virus
but he's made no actual plan as to how
he's going to shut down the virus i
understand he can hold up a little cloth
mask
but guess what again masking is really
prevalent in europe
at least in france germany italy they're
they're experiencing a second wave
they're blue areas they were hit really
hard the first time that are
experiencing a second wave
so biden's plan to quote unquote shut
down the virus it's not a plan at all
it's not even close to a plan everything
that he says is his plan is actually
trump's plan
here was biden saying that he was going
to shut down the virus not the country
but then admitting that he has not ruled
out more shutdowns
i'm going to shut down the virus not the
country it's his ineptitude that caused
the violence caused the country to have
to shut down in large part
why businesses have gone under why
schools are closed those other concerns
are real that's why
he should have been instead of in a sand
trap in his golf course he should have
been negotiating
with nancy pelosi and the rest of the
democrats and republicans about
what to do about the acts they were
passing for billions of dollars to make
sure people had the capacity
but you haven't ruled out more shutdowns
well no
okay no i haven't no i haven't ruled out
more shutdowns
and trump immediately comes back at him
and again this is good from trump he
says all he does is talk about shutdowns
it's literally all the guy does all day
long he just talks about shutdowns
democrats keep talking about shutdowns
we have to open everything is what trump
says that may be a vision that americans
are going to embrace particularly if you
have kids and democrats keep talking
about shutting down the schools
i can tell you on a firsthand level my
kids were in zoom school
from march all the way until like the
last two weeks the radical difference in
their lives
in our life since they've been able to
go to school because we are now in
florida
it's a radical difference it is not even
close their life is much better they are
learning
they are enjoying their life okay there
are a lot of people out there who are
not
on board with the lockdown culture here
was trump fighting back against biden on
this
all he does is talk about shutdowns but
forget about him
democrats democrats all they're shut
down so tight
and they're dying we're not going to
shut down and we have to open our
schools
people are losing their jobs they're
committing suicide
there's depression alcohol drugs at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
there's abuse tremendous abuse we have
to open our country
you know i've said it often the cure
cannot be worse
than the problem itself and that's
what's happening
and he wants to close down he'll close
down the country if
one person in our in our massive
bureaucracy says we should close it down
okay so that was again i thought that
the conversation would turn quickly from
trump's rhetoric to what's going to
happen from here on in that conversation
certainly
benefits trump and then you got to a
very weird biden statement sort of
conclude that conversation
in which biden suggested i mean now he's
not just cribbing from neil kinnick like
back in the 1980s
now he's just cribbing from his boss's
playbook right he's just ripping off
barack obama's playbook he does this
there are no blue states there are no
red states but also the red states suck
it was very weird here was joe biden
saying that there are no blue states or
red states but um the red states are
terrible
take a look at what new york has done in
terms of turning the curve down
in terms of the number of people dying
and i don't look at this in terms of the
way he does
blue states and red states they're all
the united states and look at the states
that are having such a spike
in the coronavirus they're the red
states
they're the states in the midwest of the
states in the upper midwest that's where
the spike is occurring significantly
but they're all americans they're all
americans and what we have to do is say
wear these masks number one make sure we
get the help that the businesses need
okay so i'm just enjoying him saying
there's no blue states and there's no
red states but the red states are really
botching this thing
but it's bad when trump says the blue
states botched this thing okay in just a
second
we're gonna get to the second message
that trump was promoting so first
message that he was promoting the early
going is that
biden is captain lockdown which is true
the second message that he was promoting
was a character message and that was
joe biden is not this clean and pristine
politician joe biden is a typical
corrupt politician we'll get to that
message
in just one second because i do think
that trump successfully made some
headway there we'll get to that in one
side first
let's talk about the fact that right now
is a terrible time to go to the auto
parts store in fact you know what's a
terrible time to go to the auto parts
store
anytime on a calendar or on your watch
that is because auto parts stores
you're gonna go there they're gonna ask
you very specific questions you're not
gonna know the answer they're gonna get
a generic part that isn't great
or they're gonna order a part online
that now takes a week and a half to
reach you and then they'll upcharge you
for having done the ordering
themselves or theoretically you could
just order it yourself and cut out the
middleman
and save money rockauto.com is the way
to do this they offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you spend up to
twice as much for the same parts
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts again rockauto.com
it's catalog unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
okay so then we moved to trump's second
line of attack
and the second line of attack for trump
is that joe biden is corrupt right the
joe biden has portrayed himself as this
nice elderly gentleman who is pure as
the driven snow
and that ain't true joe biden has been
spending 47 years picking up
little bennies on the side which is not
uncommon
but it is kind of gross right so by
trump did a good job of redirecting this
conversation so
biden suggested that trump had lied to
the american people about covid
which again the evidence is just not
there for that even bob woodward didn't
really believe
that trump knew the thing was airborne
in early february nobody the cdc didn't
say it was airborne until like july
in any case joe biden suggested that
trump
somehow concocted this bizarre wall
street scheme
where he knew that covert was going to
be really bad and so he told all of his
wall street buddies but not the american
people so they could short sell the
market
and trump came right back at him pretty
strong here was the
trump versus biden exchange he didn't
want to tell us because he didn't want
us to panic
he didn't want us americans don't panic
he panicked
but guess what in the meantime we find
out in the new york times the other day
that in fact his folks went to wall
street and said this is a really
dangerous thing
and a memo out of that meeting not from
his administration
but from some of the brokers said sell
short you're the one that takes all the
money from wall street i don't take it
you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals are
made you know i could raise so much more
money
as president and as somebody that knows
most of those people
i could call the heads of wall street
the heads of every company in america
i would blow away every record but i
don't want to do that
because it puts me in a bad position and
then you bring up wall street you
shouldn't be bringing up wall street
because you're the one that takes the
money from wall street not me okay and
joe biden looking a little awkward there
because that is the fact i mean joe
biden is out raising trump on wall
street something like five to one he's
out raising him in silicon valley
like 99 to one so the the notion
that joe biden is somehow not corrupt
and that trump is corrupt with regard to
wall street
is a pretty rich one and then it went
further right then we finally got to the
hunter biden stuff
okay so you knew that trump was going to
bring this up he didn't tell the story
wonderfully
in fact some of the stuff that he said
was an over was an overestimation of the
truth to put it kindly
that is particularly true when he was
talking about business deals in which
hunter engaged
he he kind of corrected himself as he
went on he said that it went to the
biden family which is a vague way of
sort of implying that joe was involved
without overtly saying that joe was
involved
at one point he actually said that joe
had received direct cash from the
russian government for example
that was not true but if the goal here
was to throw as much mud as possible at
joe biden
in an attempt to get people to be a
little bit less enthusiastic about biden
feel like he's just kind of you know
maybe this was aimed at the bernie bros
a little bit for trump trump did this to
hillary last time too it's like she was
taking wall street
speeches and she was a corruptocrat and
all of this he did some of the same
stuff
too to joe biden yesterday
so this this particular conversation
started off with joe biden
saying that he was going to take on
putin which is just absurd
on his face i mean he was part of an
administration that overtly
allowed russia to take over policymaking
in syria
that allowed russia to invade crimea he
was part of an
administration that removed some of the
defense capabilities of eastern european
countries
and he was the the biden biden obama
administration was awful with regard to
russia but here was joe biden just lying
about that because he did tell an awful
lot of lies last night
everything is going on here about russia
is wanting to make sure
that i do not get elected the next
president united states
because they know i know them and they
know
me i don't understand why this president
is unwilling to take on putin
okay again the the trump administration
policy is significantly harsher on
russia
than anything obama ever did in just one
second we'll get to trump's
counter-attack which again was this
line which is joe biden is corrupt he's
a long-time corrupt politician
again the fact checkers are going to
have a field day with some of the claims
that trump made here because again some
of the claims that trump made here are
just not right
but the overall implication right which
that trump was trying to make here which
is that
the bidens have been trading on the
family names when rich members of the
biden family that is that is certainly
true okay we'll get to that in one
second
biden did not really have a good defense
for it and trump hammered it
a lot last night okay we'll get to that
in just one second
now as you may know this it can be
difficult to find the right employees
for the jobs at your company and let's
say for example
that you have employees and they're all
the way across the country
and it is their job to make sure that
all the broadcasts run smoothly and so
you don't have to sit in a chair for
like an hour before time just they can
get their technicals done
well you might think to yourself well if
they don't do that job perhaps i will
head over to ziprecruiter.com
has that crossed my mind absolutely it's
crossed my mind i got to keep people on
our toes here at the daily wire
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter does all the
work for you
when you post a job on zip recruiter it
gets sent out to over 100 job sites with
just one click
then zip recruiter's powerful matching
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience
for your job and then actively invites
them to apply so you get the qualified
candidates fast it's no wonder four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get that quality candidate
within
the very first day right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
you may be stressed out about everything
going on in the world right now but
don't be stressed out about your hiring
try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire ziprecruiter is indeed the
smartest way
to hire okay so in just one second we'll
get back to
the debate because here's where it
really started to get hot and heavy but
first it is that glorious time of the
week when i give a shout out to a daily
wire member today
is seth heckman on twitter who
understands exactly what to get parents
with young children in the picture
the world's greatest beverage vessel is
resting in a box with iron man
captain america and spider-man outfits
good
stuff the caption reads just gave my
best friend the best gift i could think
of as a baby gift
superhero onesies and the leftist years
tumblr also known as the strongest
avenger
yes the power of this elite tumbler is
indeed unmatched
well done sir only only the greatest can
wield it thanks for the shout out and
being a daily wire member 2020
as you may have noticed has been a crazy
year it feels like america is coming
apart because
it kind of is there are underlying
ideological and philosophical
differences in the united states
now one of the questions i get so much
from parents college students
high school students is what do i need
to know about america's philosophy and
history what makes america unique what
is the best defense for america well i
wrote it okay it's called how to destroy
america
in three easy steps the book is about
american philosophy history and culture
why they are under attack by a
disintegrationist viewpoint that views
america as deeply evil in its inception
use american philosophy as an obstacle
to utopia and views american
institutions
as something that needs to be ripped
down go pick up my book right now how to
destroy america in three easy steps it
has never been more
more relevant it will continue to be
relevant post-election it is an
excellent primer on exactly what's
coming
not just in this election but for years
to come it's going to be the great
ideological battle and my book spells it
out right now how to destroy america in
three easy steps
also more news this sunday we have
another great episode of the sunday
special with jared kushner senior
advisor to president trump
jared joined the show to share his
experience with trump and to remind the
american people of the administration's
accomplishments
that he says will continue given four
more years in office it was a great
conversation i think that you will enjoy
it here is just a little bit of it
you know this is what i call the swamps
last stand and
and i think that this is really the last
chance for the american people to truly
have an outsider
uh in washington and hopefully when the
president wins he'll be in a position
where he'll
just accelerate the changes that he's
that he's been able to make and really
drain the swamp and truly bring you know
power in america back to the american
people
[Music]
make sure to check it out this sunday or
if you're an all access member you can
watch it a whole day earlier
head on over to dailywire.com right now
subscribers can listen
this sunday on apple podcast spotify
wherever else you get your podcast
you are listening to the fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
okay so trump had a couple of messages
first message biden is captain lockdown
he's going to lock you down he's never
going to let you out of lockdown
and honestly given how democrats are
governing
not super wrong they're still talking
about school shutdowns when the data on
school shutdowns is available
and it demonstrates school shutdowns are
a very bad idea second message trump was
trying to promote last night
is that biden is a long-time corrupt
politician so he went directly after
biden
as i say it is worth noting here that
some of these claims are just not true
and i think that for the sake of honesty
we should point out that they are not
true
however some of these claims are in fact
true they're not all false here's trump
clip 23
talking about joe biden and uh receiving
money from foreign sources or at least
his family
doing so joe got three and a half
million dollars from russia
and it came through putin because he was
very friendly with the
former mayor of moscow and it was the
mayor of moscow's wife and
you got three and a half million dollars
your family got three and a half million
dollars and
you know someday you're gonna have to
explain why did you get three to half i
think you have to clean it up and talk
to the american people maybe you can do
it right now
i have not taken a penny from any
foreign source
ever in my life we learned that this
president
paid 50 times the tax in china has a
secret bank account
with china does business in china
and in fact is talking about me taking
money
i've not taken a single penny from any
country
whatsoever ever number one number two
this is a president i have released all
of my tax returns the foreign countries
are paying you
a lot russia's paying you a lot china's
painting a lot i don't make money from
china you do i don't make money from
ukraine
you do i don't make money from russia
you made three and a half million
dollars joe and your son gave you
they even have a statement that we have
to give 10
to the big man you're the big man i
think i don't know maybe you're not
but you're the big man i think your son
said we have to give 10
to the big man joe what's that all about
okay so trump is conflating a bunch of
different claims
right here it is true that hunter biden
picked up three and a half million
dollars from the wife of moscow's mayor
it is not
true there's no evidence to suggest that
joe biden benefited from that at least
not directly
okay it is true that hunter biden was
picking up enormous checks in ukraine
based on the biden family name
it is not true or at least there is no
evidence to the effect that joe biden
was picking up any of that cash it is
true that hunter biden was picking up
bags of cash in china and this is where
things have gotten a little dicey for
biden there are emails suggesting
that perhaps joe biden had something to
do with it joe biden has denied all of
that but here's the bottom line if
you're watching this debate
and this is the first time you're
hearing any of this this does change
your impression of
joe biden just a little bit because it
turns out that joe biden actually
overstated his defense
of all of this and there is something
deeply suspicious about the fact that in
american politics and it is more typical
of all politicians
than american politics you enter office
middle class or poor
and you leave office rich that is a
weird thing
okay joe biden does own a bevy of
extremely expensive houses
this is a man who entered office really
worth nothing
his net worth right now joe biden's
is not particularly low according to
mary claire joe's worth about nine
million dollars
okay so that's a nice thing right that's
according to forbes
it was based on a total portfolio four
million bucks in real estate cash
investments worth four million bucks and
a federal pension worth more than a
million bucks
because that seems like a pretty good
living for uh for somebody who spends
his entire career in government
now some of that is fairly typical you
know kind of
nice deals that you get from your
neighbors and people who have business
before you
and just do you a favor here or there
that's not atypical
but that's kind of the point is that joe
biden is a typical swamp creature and he
has been a swamp creature for a very
long time
right here is uh and is also true by the
way that there is
very solid evidence that all of joe
biden's family members have made an
awful lot of money off of joe biden's
name over the course of joe biden's
career
here was trump going after biden again
on this
i was put through a phony witch hunt
for three years it started
before i even got elected they spied on
my campaign
no president should ever have to go
through what i went through let me just
say this mueller and 18 angry democrats
and fbi agents all over the place spent
48 million dollars
they went through everything i had
including my tax returns
and they found absolutely no collusion
and nothing wrong
48 million i guarantee you if i spent 1
million on youtube i could find plenty
wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done and the kind of monies that your
family has taken
i mean your brother made money in iraq
millions of dollars
your other brother made a fortune and
it's all through you joe and they say
you get some of it
and you do live very well you have
houses all over the place
okay and again joe biden kind of
laughing that one off but
he is worth nine million dollars now
some of that i'm sure is book money i'm
sure a lot of that is pension
but again there are serious questions to
be asked about why it is that every
member of our public
codery goes into office poor and leaves
office rich okay that is a that is a
real thing
this did lead joe biden to actually
overtly say something that is not true
okay and that was he he didn't just
claim that he had done nothing unethical
which again he can claim
and he can claim that he never violated
the law and frankly
i sort of believe that i don't see any
evidence that joe biden violated the law
when he says that hunter never did
anything unethical there you start to
really
i mean hunter admitted on national tv
that he used his daddy's name to traffic
in ukraine said he could make a butt
load of money i mean that that is
overtly when he says hunter never did
anything unethical
now joe biden has linked himself with
hunter he's tied himself to hunter and
this is a huge political error it also
happens to be a lie that the trump that
hunter never did anything unethical
nothing was unethical here's what's the
deal his son
didn't have a job for a long time was
sadly no longer in
the military service i won't get into
that and he didn't have a job
as soon as he became vice president
barisma not the best look
not the best reputation in the world i
hear they paid him 183
000 a month listen to this 183
and they gave him a 3 million dollar
upfront payment all right and he had no
energy i'm going to let the vice
president respond to that quickly and
then i need to get to a question to you
very
oh basis for that everybody investigated
that no one said anything he did was
wrong in ukraine
nobody said that anything hunter biden
did in ukraine was wrong
okay there's a difference in legally
wrong and i'm using my vp daddy's name
to
make bank on a natural gas company in
burisma while my dad is in charge of
ukraine policy in fact the remembers
that i mean it's overtly false the state
department
warned the obama administration that
this looked corrupt and people were told
don't talk to joe about it because he's
too concerned about what's going on with
bo because bo at the time was suffering
from brain cancer
so no that's just not true that's just
not true
and trump kept hammering this home like
over and over he kept hammering this
home and finally
biden responded and this was i thought
maybe the best moment of the night
for donald trump joe biden finally got
tired of all of this
and he pivoted to what was obviously a
pre-planned response right
every that before a debate you always
write a few responses
knowing exactly what's coming by knew
this was going to come up and he was
waiting to deploy it
and finally he deployed his pre-planned
response there's only one problem
trump absolutely walloped him over it
this is the worst moment of the debate
for biden bar none this is clip 27
he doesn't want to talk about the the
the substance of issues
it's not about his family and my family
it's about your family
and your family's hurting badly if
you're making less than
if you're a middle class family you're
getting hurt
badly right now that's a second local
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything
just a typical politician when i see
that let's talk about a difficult
politician okay
that's why i got elected okay so that is
a great
debate tactic okay he just chris
christie them do you remember back in
2016 chris christie
marco rubio they're in a debate and
christy committed the world's first
political murder suicide he was already
basically done with the race and so he
just took out rubio rubio had a shot at
taking out trump in new hampshire
and christy looked at ruby and said what
you're going to say right now
is that make no mistake blah blah blah
and then rubio came back he said make no
mistake blah blah blah
and everybody went oh boom christy
called you up
okay that tactic is the most obnoxious
tactic when somebody goes faux sincere
when some when a serious issue is being
discussed and then suddenly
the candidate turns to the camera and
says the american people don't want to
hear this the american people want to
hear about the things that affect them
for trump to call that out and be like
joe you're still full of crap i mean
honestly
you're like we're in the middle of a
conversation about family corruption and
now you're gonna do the kitchen table
yeah yeah you're a typical politician
it's why i got elected it was the best
moment for trump
it was very very funny it was the best
moment for trump all night
and again highlight the fact that trump
is not your typical politician which in
many cases
is not ideal but in this case it's kind
of ideal
that's kind of a good thing okay that is
not where the debate ended
and thus we continue so the debate then
turned to foreign policy
biden put out one of the weirder lines
of the night he invoked godwin's law
which
really i mean he just brought up hitler
randomly in the middle of the debate
so trump was talking about north korea
and he has a good relationship with kim
jong-un
and uh and then biden started dropping
weird historical references that just
don't make any sense
so here was here's a bit of that they
tried to meet with him
he wouldn't do it north korea we're not
in a war we have a good relationship
you know people don't understand having
a good relationship with leaders of
other countries
we have a lot of questions to get to
know man we had a good relationship with
hitler before he in fact
invaded europe the rest of europe come
on
come on okay so as you will see at the
end of this
particular debate we're going to do a
montage of how many times joe biden said
come on
if joe biden keeps going back to come on
that doesn't tell he is not doing well
in the debate
he was not doing well in the debate in
fact the united states did not have a
good relationship with hitler in the
lead up to world war ii
joe biden later said he was joking there
was no evidence that he was joking that
was not a joke
okay he actually the joke doesn't even
make any sense if he thinks that we had
a bad relationship like
that doesn't make any sense at all like
it just undercuts what he's trying to
say
right there then the debate turned to
health care
so this is where i thought kristen
walker who i thought was pretty good all
night
she asked a question about health care
but channeled it through the prism of
amy coney beard it was really weird she
was like
amy coney barrett is being nominated for
the supreme court there's an obamacare
case before the supreme court this is
why democrats oppose amy coney bears
like no that is not why democrats oppose
amy coney barrett nonetheless the
conversation turned to health care
and as the debate went on biden started
to drop more and more whoppers
so the whopper of the night was this one
so biden was talking
about obamacare and his new plan which
is a public option
now let it be known a public option only
works so the public option is not just
for people who are not able to obtain
private health insurance you're allowed
to opt into the private option
into the public option which means that
one of two things has to happen with the
public option in order for people to
want to opt into it
one you have to undermine public
insurance private insurance rather or
two you have to subsidize
public insurance so either you have to
mandate the doctors take the public
insurance
you have to mandate the doctors take a
crappier form of insurance and
reimbursement or
you have to subsidize the public option
insurance such that it is actually
better than private insurance but you're
doing it with taxpayer dollars and you
run private insurance out of business
everybody who takes this seriously
understands the public options are
generally designed
to run private industry into the ground
they allow for the possibility of
supplemental insurance
specialty insurance you see this in some
areas of europe
but when it comes to overall private
health insurance everybody understands
that a public option
is designed as a first step toward
getting rid of your private health
insurance plans because either you have
to
restrict doctors so that they must take
public insurance
in which case it's cheaper for me not to
pay for my private insurance through my
employer
and just take the public option or they
have to subsidize the public option in
which case it is cheaper for me to go
and take the public option
right the purpose of a public option is
not to provide competition
it is not competition it is a monopoly a
government public option is a monopoly
okay so all of that happens to be the
case but
joe biden issued a whopper last night of
cataclysmic proportions
he said that nobody lost their private
insurance under obamacare
this is just a lie okay in 2013 the
left-wing fact-checking site politifact
declared it was their lie of the year
when barack obama said that nobody would
lose their health insurance plan under
obamacare
and yet here is joe biden repeating it
nonetheless
as you will see the fact checkers after
the debate they assured us that joe
biden is just
he's a nice old guy who barely ever lies
this is just here he is repeating maybe
the great lie of the decade
here is joe biden what i'm going to do
is
pass obamacare with a public option or
become biden care the public option
is an option that says that if you in
fact do not have the wherewithal to be
if you qualify for medicaid
and you do not have the wherewithal in
your state to get medicaid you
automatically are enrolled
providing competition for insurance
companies that's what's going to happen
secondly
we're going to make sure we reduce the
premiums and reduce drug prices
by making sure that there's competition
that doesn't exist now by allowing
the medicare to negotiate drug prices
with the insurance companies thirdly
the idea that i want to eliminate
private insurance the reason why i had
such a fight for
with 20 candidates for the nomination
was i
support private insurance that's why i
did
not one single person with private
insurance would lose their insurance
under my plan
nor did they under obamacare so he's
lying about his own policy and he's
lying about obamacare his policy does
not merely
relegate public option to people who
cannot obtain private insurance
it allows anybody to opt into the public
option
okay this opened up the final line of
attack for trump
so there were three lines of attack for
trump last night one is that joe biden
is locked down king
second is that joe biden is corrupt and
third is that joe biden never got
anything done he's been in government
his entire life and he's never gotten
anything done
he points this out last night he was
here
before 47 years he didn't do it he was
now there as vice president for eight
years and it's not like it was 25 years
ago it was
three and three quarters it was just a
little while ago right
less than four years ago he didn't do
anything he didn't do it
he wants socialized medicine and it's
not that he wants it his vice president
i mean she is is more liberal
than bernie sanders you're going to have
socialized medicine just like you want
to with fracking
we're not going to have fracking we're
going to stop fracking we're going to
stop fracking he's talking about
destroying your medicare
total and destroying your social
security and this whole country will
come down you know bernie sanders tried
it
in his state he thinks he's running
against somebody else he's running
against
joe biden i beat all those other people
because i disagreed with them
okay while i'm enjoying joe biden face
planting bernie sanders like
giving him the swirly sticking his face
in the toilet and flushing it which is
exactly what
biden's doing right there he's saying i
don't agree with bernie i don't like
medicare for all that's why i'm here and
bernie isn't
recognize that the public option is
again step one on the road towards
socialized medicine pretty much
everybody
understands that is the reality okay the
debate next
turned to stimulus packages and the
economy
and biden suggested this is a very weird
democratic talking point that when the
stock market goes up it doesn't help
people that's just a lie about half of
americans have some sort of stock in the
market
and pretty much everybody's 401k is
invested in the market largely union
members right i mean there are huge
union pension funds that are relegated
to the that are heavily invested in the
stock market trump said the stock market
is booming
and biden was like well you know nobody
cares about the stock market
well um no actually a lot of people care
about the stock market as it turns out
they said stock market if i'm elected
if he's elected the stock market will
crash the idea that the stock market is
booming is his only measure
of what's happening where i come from in
scranton and claim on that people don't
live off of the stock market
just in the uh just in the last three
three years during this crisis
the billionaires in this country made
according to the
wall street 700 billion more dollars
700 billion more dollars because that's
his only measure
what happens to the ordinary people out
there what happens to them
let's talk 401k
he doesn't come from scranton that's
like one of he
lived there for a short period of time
before he even knew we're going to move
on and he left
okay again like people think that sort
of stuff doesn't matter and it probably
doesn't
but it's a little bit it matters a
little bit that joe biden is
consistently telling his kind of little
lies about
his past okay and then they talked about
stimulus
and the fact that democrats have been
obstructing the stimulus package that
happens
independents believe that nancy pelosi
is the obstructive factor who will not
allow stimulus to go forward kristen
welker finally asked a good question of
joe biden she said
okay you keep declaring you're the head
of the democratic party and you're
pushing nobody to get any deal done
and here is joe biden just lying about
what the stimulus deal is
why have you not pushed the democrats to
get a deal for the american people well
i have and they have pushed it look they
passed this act
all the way back in the beginning of the
summer bill that was passed in the house
was a bailout of badly run high
crime democrat all run by democrats
cities and states
it was a way of getting a lot of money
billions and billions of dollars to
these skates
it was also a way of getting a lot of
money from our people's pockets to
people that come into our country
illegally i'm running as a proud
democrat i'm going to be an american
president
i don't see red states and blue states
what i see
is american united states and folks
every single state out there
finds themselves in trouble okay captain
turn to the camera here uh
okay that is not true red states have
not run up anything like the deficits
that new york and california have run up
this is a bailout for blue states
everybody understands that
basically whenever blue states do badly
joe biden says he doesn't see red states
or blue states the minute that resides
too badly suddenly he's talking about
the evils of red states
weird weird how that works okay then the
debate turned to illegal immigration
and there are a lot of people last night
who started to put out misinformation on
on what trump actually said on the stage
so there is a lot of talk about the
story of some 500 kids
who were separated from their parents at
the border because the way the law works
is that either you have to release the
entire family
into the interior of the united states
or you have to separate the kids from
the parents right that is according to
ninth circuit court of appeals law
so when they talk about forced family
separation the idea that there's an
actual
settlement called the flora settlement
and it was put into place years and
years and years ago
the basic idea is that you were not
allowed to hold parents and children in
custody
right you either had to separate the two
by allowing the kids
to be placed with with other adults
outside of custody and you keep the
parents there
or you have to release everybody into
the interior so
this came up last night because it turns
out that it's been difficult to
reunify these kids with their parents
well in some cases it's difficult to
reunify them with their parents because
some of the people who are being who
bring them over were not in fact their
parents right they're brought with
adults
not all of them were brought with their
parents because trump
correctly pointed out that coyotes bring
people across the border
adults bring kids across the border and
then the kids have no
adult to actually be with it's not as
though their parents came across with
them
in some cases apparently the parents
were deported and the government is
trying to find the parents so the kids
can be reunified
with the parents in the first place but
the kids are living presumably with
family members
or in conditions provided by the
american federal government that's bad
it's terrible it's very very sad but you
have a couple of choices one is you can
either release everybody into the
interior of the country and the other is
you can engage in this
forced family separation policy the
trump administration has started
releasing people into the interior of
the country more because they didn't
like the bad press
here is here is this issue came up and
it started to uh look bad for trump here
because whenever there's a human issue
that tugs at the heartstrings
and it looks like you're on the wrong
side people start to get very angry at
you
but trump immediately flipped this and
it was a bad moment for joe biden
because the reality is that joe biden
and barack obama initiated family
separation policy
during their administration here was
donald trump going after
going after joe biden children are
brought here
by coyotes and lots of bad people
cartels and they're brought here and
they used to use them to get into our
country
we now have as strong a border as we've
ever had
we're over 400 miles of brand new wall
you see the numbers and we let people in
but they have to come in legally and
they come in through but how are you
reuniting
with their families they built cages you
know they used to say i built the cages
and then it was determined they were
built
in 2014 that was him a lot of these kids
come out without the parents
these 500 plus kids came with
parents they separated them at the
border
who built the cages let's talk about who
built the cages
okay and that was the big question right
and joe couldn't answer it because the
fact is that it was the obama
administration that built the cages
and then biden kept going on about all
the things he was going to do with
regard to illegal immigration and trump
went back to
again that third theme which is that joe
biden has been in government forever and
never did anything
about any of this stuff he had eight
years
to do what he said he was going to do
and i've changed
without having a specific we got rid of
catch and release
we got rid of a lot of horrible things
that they put in
and that they lived with but he had
eight years he was vice president
he did nothing except build
cages to keep children in he has no
understanding of immigration of the laws
catch and release is a disaster
a murderer would come in a rapist would
come in
a very bad person would come in we would
take their name
we have to release them into our country
and then you say they come back less
than one percent of the people
come back we have to send ice out and
border patrol out to find them
we would say come back in two years
three years
we're going to give you a court case you
need perry mason we're going to give you
a court case
when you say they come back they don't
come back joe those with the lowest iq
they might come back what he's telling
you is simply not true okay so
it isn't true that only one percent of
people show up for their court date most
people
apparently about 50 of people 75 of
people by various estimates
show up for that initial court date the
problem is there's a secondary court
date that is set and usually that never
comes to pass so
the one percent statistic is not coming
from a place that i can verify for sure
but it is true the catch and release
policy is a garbage policy and it has
released
not 11 million illegal immigrants into
the center of the country it has
released
many many more illegal immigrants
probably closer to 520 million illegal
immigrants
in the country at this point but again
trump's main point here which is that
joe biden
he keeps promising things and he's been
in the government forever he's not wrong
and again trump kept hammering this home
they turned to the issue of race and
trump
kept hammering at home right there here
was cl trump clip 38
saying that uh you know you keep talking
about how you're going to heal all the
racial wounds of the country
where have you been for the past several
decades yes i do
and again he's been in government 47
years he never did a thing
except in 1995 when he did
such harm to the black community and
they were called
and he called them super predators
nobody has done more for the black
community than donald trump and if you
look
with the exception of abraham lincoln
possible exception but the exception of
abraham lincoln
nobody has done what i've done okay
this culminated with a very
very weak exchange for joe biden
right all of this this this third line
of attack that biden's been in
government forever and never done
anything
this this culminated in a really
terrible moment i thought
for joe biden this is this would be clip
41.
okay this is where biden tries to
explain how he was
wrong about all of his criminal justice
policies now what's hilarious about this
is that he actually was not wrong about
all of his criminal justice policies one
of his only signal career
accomplishments
was actually lowering the crime rate via
the 1994 crime bill and via some of the
drug bills in the 1980s the crack
epidemic was horrible
in the 1980s the crime epidemic was
horrible in the early 90s
but he has to run directly away from
that because his own party hates it so
here was joe biden explaining what he's
going to do now and trump again hammers
him with
okay so why didn't you do it you've been
here for 50 years
why didn't you do it and biden's answer
is so stunningly and blindingly bad that
it actually stops the debate dead
in the 80s we passed 100 percent all 100
senators voted for it
a bill on drugs and how to deal with
drugs it was a mistake
i've been trying to change the sense and
particularly the portion on cocaine
that's why i've been arguing that in
fact we should not
send anyone to jail for a
pure drug offense they should be going
into treatment
why didn't you do it in the eight years
a short time ago
why didn't you do it you just said i'm
going to do that i'm going to do this
you put of thousands of mostly
black young men in prison now you're
saying you're gonna get
you're gonna undo that why didn't you
get it done you had eight years with
obama
you know why joe because you're all talk
and no action all right vice president
biden and then we're going to move on to
the next section
we've got a republican congress
that's the answer okay you got to talk
them into it you know
all right you got to talk them into it
we're going to move on to our next
section like i did with criminal justice
reform
i had to talk democrats into gentlemen
we're running out of time so we got to
get on to
climate change please okay so joe biden
stops absolutely dead after he says
we had a republican congress no you
didn't
for the first two years of the barack
obama administration not only did
democrats have a majority in the house
they had a super majority in the senate
they had a filibuster-proof majority in
the senate
okay for the first two years of the
obama administration that's how they got
obamacare done
they didn't lose the house until 2010
and they didn't lose the senate until
2014.
so it's just not true what he's saying
there is overtly untrue
okay the bottom line is that he is all
talk he doesn't do anything
trump is right about that okay the final
bad point for joe biden
happened late in the debate they're
talking about environmentalism and
biden has this very weird take that
climate change is going to kill all
humanity and so he has pledged
all of these radical policies that he
actually probably doesn't like very much
and this culminated in what was probably
the biggest boo-boo of the entire debate
and it will be in
all of the campaign ads leading up to
election day particularly in
pennsylvania
this is clip 45. so trump is hammering
him on fracking
right trump is just saying you said that
you want to ban fracking and by is like
no i said i want to ban it on federal
lands okay he's actually said
broadly speaking that he does want to
ban fracking and then he said oh yeah by
the way i only meant federal lands but
there's i mean there's tape of him
saying over and over and over again that
he would like to transition away from
fracking
or ban fracking or end fracking then
he'll say well i'll just do it on
federal lands okay fine
trump gets him to admit in this clip
that he wants to end
the oil industry that he wants to
destroy the entire oil industry in the
united states
that is responsible for millions and
millions of jobs
if you don't think this is going to be
an issue in pennsylvania wrong you are
here was trump getting biden to admit
that he wishes to kill the entire oil
industry of the united states by the way
we just became energy independent
because of fracking in the oil industry
would you close down the air by the way
i have a transition from the oil
industry yes
oh transition that is a big statement
because
i would stop why would you do that
because the oil industry
pollutes significantly i said here's the
deal but
that's a big statement well if you let
me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
to the gas
exchange to the uh to uh solar and wind
yeah why are we giving it to oil
industry we actually do
solar and wind that's maybe the biggest
statement in terms of business
that's the biggest thing because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma vice
president biden let me give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have to
get to the final question
vice president biden he takes everything
out of context no you literally just
said it one second ago he did not in
fact take it out of context that was you
one seconds ago declaring that you were
going to end the oil industry in the
united states of america okay so
no that one's on you and that's gonna be
in every campaign ad and it should be in
every campaign and there were a couple
of indicators by the way
uh there are three real indicators that
biden lost this debate
and two of these indicators came from
biden directly so again his tell is when
he says come on
he said come on 1 000 times last night
because when he gets tired and he
doesn't have anything to say
he just kind of throws up his hands and
goes come on come on
here's a montage of joe biden's come ons
last night this is clip 12.
it's all gonna be over soon come on
learning to live with it
come on not that many of you are gonna
die so don't worry about it
so don't worry about it come on i know
how to game the system
come on come on folks we had a good
relationship with hitler before he in
fact invaded
europe the rest of europe come on is
lecturing me
on social security and medicare come on
let him go bankrupt come on i told him
to stand down
and stand ready come on that is
nine commands nine
in the course of the debate okay that is
how you know he's losing otherwise you
know he's losing he actually starts
glancing at his watch in the middle of
the debate
he's like when is this over i really
have to pay when is this over
here is uh some footage of joe biden
glancing at his watch pretty overtly in
the middle of the camp in the middle of
the debate
there he was good luck there from slow
joe okay
the final way that you know that this
debate did not go well for joe biden is
the media reaction
so the media were apoplectic over this
apoplectic
over this they reveal themselves each
and every day and it really is
incredible
how bad was joe biden basically
everybody on the democratic side had to
start reversing
their own positions and or lying okay so
frank luntz
had a focus group last night that focus
group described
the various candidates according to
frank luntz's focus group
the words to describe trump were
controlled reserved poised con artist
and surprisingly presidential
the words to describe biden were vague
unspecific elusive
defensive and grandfatherly okay i feel
like
a lot of that is accurate and those are
not words that
really bear in in joe biden's favor
okay so how do you know that that biden
lost because number one when the media
declared to draw that means by the lost
number two you have people like joy reid
suddenly flipping and defending the 1994
crime bill so joy reid
hates the 1994 crime bill on msnbc but
she recognizes that she must defend the
precious joe biden and so here she was
defending the 1994 crime bill all of a
sudden yes
he did uh spearhead the crime bill
but let's just remember that there are a
lot of african-american
elected officials including in congress
who voted for the crime bill and who
wanted the crime bill the context was
the crack epidemic was tearing through
black communities and black
pastors were demanding a bill he put
that bill together that also included an
assault weapons ban
it also included the violence against
women act let's just remember the
context
oh the context now and this is the key
when the media have to contextualize
biden he lost
hey daniel dale the garbage fact checker
for cnn
you know he he is um he has this habit
of reeling off every inaccuracy that
trump makes in a row
and he's good at that and then
completely downplaying anything that joe
biden says
he tweeted out last night after the
debate biden was again imperfect
from a imperfect from a fact-checking
perspective he made at least a few false
misleading
and or lacking in context claims trump
was as usual
a serial liar this is what the
fact-checking
industry is designed to do it is
designed to excuse democrats while
clobbering republicans that is what it
is designed to do
daniel dale is a partisan hack he's a
hack of hacks the biggest
lie of the night belonged to joe biden
suggesting that obamacare didn't force
anybody off their private insurance that
is nuts
okay daniel dale down played that
because you know trump says things that
are inaccurate yeah no bleep have you
ever met the guy
have you ever seen him of course that's
true jake tapper was beside himself last
night on cnn
he said it was the dirtiest campaign
ever
he is running the single most
negative sleazy campaign in american
history for a major party candidate
the campaign that trump and his allies
and the media and his member members of
his family and the trump
allied uh websites and such are leveling
with charges so heinous i'm not even
going to say them
just nonsense crap tied into q anon tied
into pizzagate tied into the worst
things you could say about a person
with no evidence just completely made up
is so
disgusting and so beneath
what this election should be all right
so bottom line
is this gonna make like a huge
difference in the future of the
presidential campaign
i don't think it'll make an enormous
difference to the future of the
presidential campaign
i do think that marginal differences
particularly in swing states are going
to matter an
awful awful lot if the polls tighten in
the last week
as you would generally expect them to
then it will be seen that this debate
mattered it didn't necessarily matter to
people who
were partisans there aren't a lot of
people who are on the fence
but if it made some people less
uncomfortable about voting trump
then it did him a world of good and it
shifted in terms of the debate because
the last week
is going to be all about joe biden
declaring that he wants to enter the oil
industry
i mean that that is going to be the the
trump campaign because they need
pennsylvania that is going to be the
trump campaign for the next week
okay quick bible mode since it is a
friday and i feel like ending on an up
note we've gone back to doing bible
sections here on the ben shapiro show
because we restarted the reading of the
torah
every uh every year we do this so this
week's parsha this week's torah portion
is the parsha of noah
it's the parsha about noah so we all
know the noah story
right god looks at humanity he's like
you guys suck here's a flood
bam he says to noah why don't you
preserve your family
and uh preserve all the animals and noah
builds the ark and and the animals come
in two by two
and all of that so there's one
particular verse that's kind of
fascinating because it does have
a lot of relevance to how we think of
ourselves and what our mission is
today so it says is genesis 6 9
these are the generations of noah noah
is a righteous man he was perfect in his
generations
noah walked with god so there's a big
debate among jewish commentators about
what it means when it says that noah was
perfect in his generations
why does it say he was perfect in his
time why why
because theoretically if he was perfect
it wouldn't just be
in his time so is that a compliment or
is that a derogatory
if you say that somebody is great in
their time that can mean one of two
things one the time is really awful so
the fact that they were great in that
awful time means they were even greater
than they normally would be
you're a great person living in nazi
germany well by contrast or even greater
because you're living in an awful awful
time
or does it mean that you were great
compared to the other people of your
time and since they sucked
you were better than they were but but
if you put them in like a normal time
they'd be kind of normal right there's
actually a debate among jewish
commentators
i tend to come down on the side that
suggests that
if you are great over that it is better
to be great overall than to be great
in your time what separates noah from
the other characters of the bible
so god tells noah i'm destroying all of
humanity right it's over
here comes the flood and noah does not
respond the same way that abraham or
moses do so abraham is told by god that
he's going to destroy
sodom and gomorrah and abraham's first
response is let me argue with you
let's let's think this one out a little
bit right let's let's try and identify
are there any good people who are living
in sodom and gomorrah is it 100 men is
it 50 men is it 10 men can we find
anybody there who's good
for who's sake it's worth preserving the
entire city right he argues with god he
has a moral debate with god
moses is informed by god at one point
that god is so angry he's gonna destroy
the entire jewish people
and he's going to make a nation of moses
and his kids and moses argues against
that and he says if you do that i want
you to blot me out of your book
like literally don't have me in your
book i'm not interested in what you're
talking about here god
right those are great men for the ages
noah when he's confronted with the
possibility of an entire generation
being blotted off the face of the earth
he does exactly what god tells him and
he doesn't protest
so that is the distinction right that's
the distinction
if you're gonna be a great person for
all time it's not just
about being great for yourself or being
great for your family or preserving your
family or removing yourself from the
grid
it is about attempting to save the
people around you it's about attempting
to convince the people around you and
this has ramifications for today's
politics on the right there's a lot of
debate on the right
we live in a time where our culture is
extraordinarily
degraded our culture has moved wildly to
the left
our public institutions have been taken
over by people who don't believe
in american founding principle it's been
taken over by people who
openly scorn judeo-christian ideology
and ideas
so we have a couple of choices one is we
can take the sort of roger benedict
option
that is an option and in our personal
lives i think you somehow at times do
have to go off the ground i don't think
rod is completely wrong
but that is being a good person in
your generation being a good person in
all generations means fighting back in
the public sphere
in order to retake those values and
convince people of the the
the veracity of those values and the
reality of those values and the
importance of those values
that's what makes you a good person for
all time so we should all strive to be a
good pre a good we should strive
to be more than noah was uh not not just
to build the ark and preserve that which
we have
but also to go forth to shine a light to
be like abraham not like noah to open
our tent to everybody
and to try and draw people in to a
better way of life and a better
philosophy alrighty we'll be back here
next week for the final week
of the presidential campaign of 2020.
we're almost there guys
it's getting pretty exciting i'm
benchmark this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowski our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clinton
you